ils ont une semaine pour financer leur
projet c'est le nom du programme lancé
par la mairie de trappe il y a 2 ans en
échange de 5 jours de travaux de
rénovation dans les quartiers de la
ville ces jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
reçoivent un salaire de 200 € à 16 ans
mervy a déjà fait des stages mais c'est
sa première expérience professionnelle
au début j'ai voulu faire ça parce que
d'un coup pour que le temps il passe
j'apend quelque chose et à la fin
l'argent en fait je pense donner à mes
par pour partir en vacances un voyage en
Turquie pour une nouvelle chambre pour
Ilas ou encore le code pour Burgess ils
ont tous dû détailler leur motivation
dans un dossier accompagné d'un CV la
semaine dernière pour le coup d'envoi de
cette nouvelle édition c'était opération
coup de peinture dans le hall de l'école
maternelle PERG ils apprennent à ce que
justement on est avec une équipe
professionnelle donc un peintre
professionnel qui vient nous encadrer et
il nous explique comment on fait
justement la peinture c'est pas juste
mettre un petit coup de pinceau et comme
ça donc il y a des techniques à voir
comment protéger les sols comment tout
ce qui est grattage tout ça donc toute
une technique à quiir à la fin de la
semaine les murs ont bien changé ça a
beaucoup changé par rapport à la
dernière fois donc tu es fier de ton
travail oui je suis fier on est fier c
bien grâce à une simple autorisation
parentale elle a pu bénéficier d'un
contrat pour mineur une véritable
expérience d'entreprise pour ces jeunes
il y a surtout une volonté à la
base c'est de permettre aux jeunes
d'avoir une première expérience
professionnelle en fait il a êt assez
difficile au niveau des jeunes de de se
confronter comment dire à l'emploi au
marché du travail donc c'est c'est c'est
dans cette démarche là après le succès
des années précédentes le programme est
passé d'une vingtaine de places à plus
de 80 cette année les 17 prochains
chantiers ont lieu à partir de la
mi-juin et jusqu'au mois de
novembre